borgès et le clézio enfin apostrophe
enfin parce qu'il ya bien longtemps que
je rêvais nous les présenter et par le
plus grand des hasards du voici tous les
deux dans la même émission
je rappelle que ce genre d'entretien
s'adresse surtout à ceux qui ont la
chance de ne pas connaître encore et de
ne pas avoir lu encore ces deux
écrivains jeudi la chance parce que de
tous les plaisirs celui de la découverte
m'a toujours paru être le plus excitant
voici le 250e numéro d' apostrophes
consacrer d'abord à jmg le clézio et
ensuite à changer luis borgès
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme je vous le disais la semaine
dernière le clézio déjà son nom dans
tous les dictionnaires une important que
40 ans mais en dix sept ans il a publié
14 livres traduits dans le monde entier
et qui ont fait de lui le meilleur
écrivain français de sa génération
en 1963 il obtenu le prix renaudot avec
son premier livre son premier roman
procès verbal et on a su tout de suite
ce serait un écrivain important cause de
son style à cause de sa sensibilité son
intelligence et depuis n'a cessé de
raconter dans une langue simple belle
que m'inspirait il n'a cessé de raconter
à la fois les beautés et les pièges et
aliénation du monde moderne pour le
clézio l'homme est encombrant c'est un
rapace est la première victime de ce
rapace s'est lui-même may en chacun de
nous un désir de pureté un désir
d'absolu
l'enfance est un paradis perdu et nous
ne se sent de regretter de l'avoir perdu
est ce pour autant que le clézio da
mystique en tout cas c'est un écrivain
qui fuit les micros et les caméras
et ce n'est pas un hasard si dans son
dernier roman il fait l'éloge du silence
de la soif et du désert faut-il vous
appeler jean marie gustave le clézio ou
jmg le clézio comme il est indiqué sur
la couverture de vos livres
c'est comme vous voulez je veux bien
vous m'appeliez jmg l'occasion surtout
que j'aime beaucoup ma jmg l'occasion
parce que je trouve ça fait un peu non
de voitures de motos
j'ai une jmg le clézio pour sa très très
beau et comme on a souvent parlé des
voitures et c'est un nom de passeports
aussi c'est un an de passeport oui c'est
à dire que j'ai un passeport mauricien
et sur mon passeport mots et seysses
écrit jmg le clézio on ne met pas le
prénom mais les initiales dans votre
premier roman le procès-verbal
personnage principal qui s'appelait adam
paulo vivait dans une une villa sur la
côte d'azur il en sortait rarement mes
temps en temps il écrivait sur son
papier sur son paquet de cigarettes il
écrivait que notation à la fois pour une
sorte d de mémoire une temps de journal
intime un peu bizarre à une taie acheter
à manger le papier journaux et puis ils
mettaient peu pas cette formule faire un
effort pour voir le monde j'ai
l'impression que je aujourd'hui parce
que je sais que vous craignez beaucoup
les caméras que vous faites un petit peu
un effort pour pourvoir du monde on
pourrait être vu par le monde oui mais
c'est la même chose
oui c'est un petit peu la même chose non
ce n'est pas que je crains les caméras
mais simplement que je pense qu'il ne
faut pas ne faut pas trop parler il ne
faut pas trop s'expliquer c'est pourquoi
parce que on risque de ne pas dire
exactement ce qu'on voulait dire et on
risque un petit peu de
de ne pas être exact d'inventer
l'écriture est bien supérieure pour ça
parce que on ne se laisse pas emporter
par les mots contre il écrit me
contrôler oui mais comment gagner des
gens à l'écriture comment faire lire
jmg le clézio si nous n'avons pas de
temps en temps une interview dans la
presse écrite et un entretien à la radio
ou à la télévision
oui enfin je pense que c'est sympa
surtout par le par le livre pas con un
écrivain est connu surtout parce qu'il a
écrit par tellement parce qu'il fait ou
parce qu'ils ont dit oui alors je
commence cet entretien à mon avis d'une
très mauvaise façon parce que oui je
fais référence à votre premier livre le
procès-verbal dire que je fais et à un
petit peu de la culture je sais que ça
vous agace beaucoup car c'est vrai qu'il
ya quelque chose un peu redondant sorte
de duel entre eux entre vous et moi j'ai
l'impression de vous dire bon vous avez
écrit yves au livre mais moi je les ai
lus alors au fond je suis aussi fort que
vous et ça je sais que cela vous agace
un peu peut-être pas tort ça ne m'agace
pas mais je pense que mon écrivain et
nouveaux à chaque fois qu'il fait un
livre c'est à dire que ce n'est pas un
nouveau livre c'est un peu un nouvel
écrivain chaque fois on est nouveau
chaque fois qu'on écrit un nouveau lieu
contrairement à le clézio borgès lui
adore parler donner des interviews on
raconte même quinze jours à buenos aires
un journal humoristique est paru avec ce
titre exceptionnellement dans ce numéro
pas d'interview de borgès borgès est à
lui seul une tour de babel
il parle de nombreuses langues il sait
tout les étymologies toutes les
littératures
il approfondit toutes les cultures une
babel sans fenêtre puisqu'il est aveugle
une feu une babel vieillissant puisqu'il
a 81 ans mais une babel sans désordre
rigoureuse qui a gardé intacte sa
fabuleuse mémoire et son inlassable
curiosité et qui respire la culture
comme d'autres simplement respire
l'oxygène l'univers de borgès les livres
et les mots et à travers les mots par
delà leur sens et leur musique nous
faisons irruption dans la poésie le
fantastique et la métaphysique jamais
les mots ont été plus aimé que par
l'argentin borgès georges et luis borgès
nous sommes ici à la fondation simonet
du cas vous avez reçu le prix mondial
otieno del duca pour l'ensemble de votre
oeuvre c'était donc un prix de
couronnement et il y a à peu près 20 ans
vous avez reçue à formentor le prix
international de littérature qui est
elle a aussi décerné par des
intellectuels français et il ya
maintenant le trahir c'est notamment il
y avait roger caillois le regretté enfin
c'est l'homme qui vous a découvert et
lancé en france si l'on peut dire
et donc il ya vingt ans c'était un prix
de découverte aujourd'hui donc c'est un
prêt de consécration et vous avez donc
votre tête a reçu beaucoup de lauriers
littéraire c'est une voiture pourquoi
mais ça c'est de la méthode rivalis a dû
vous arrivez en espagne je suppose
benguigui en argentine et probablement
emprunté vous avez mal et moi je t'ai
pas cher monsieur dit ensuite vous
n'avez encore rien vu non sont très
discrets oui ça peut venir
ça peut venir à tout est possible et oui
ça peut venir l'avenir est infinie mais
enfin cette pratique des prix
littéraires remonte comme vous le savez
à l'antiquité grecque est ce que vous y
êtes favorable en amont qu'un jeu le
suisse a pris de l'altitude avec émotion
je ne suis pas digne
même si julien mas je reçois même avis
demain il sera rejoint d'autres pour est
entrepris peut-être le vrai prix c'est
le fait de lire et réfléchir de rêver
prémédité et découvre ensuite de tout
cela
l'aller elle même et puis d'être lu ce
n'est pas son contrat jamais aux
lecteurs quand j'écris je te lis déjà
pour pour s'engager
j'écris pour moi j'étais libéré d'un
sujet je ne cherche pas le thème le
thème mais cherche alors quand des
thèmes insiste je tâcherai l'écrire puis
une fois que je l'écris cela coûte me
donne beaucoup de la peine
il ya toujours bien des brouillons
derrière au fond de chaque page que je
crie puis ta jolie je le publie pour
penser à autre chose et quand j'ai vu me
un livre tu l'oubli son succès au
recomptage mais je tenais m'intéresse
pas je passe toujours à ce que je vais
écrire c'est que j'écris je laisse
rêveur mois de brouille entre jungle
mois
petite plaisance c'est le nom de la
modeste et jolie maison blanche
qu'habite marguerite yourcenar dans
l'île de mon désert situé dans l'état du
maine nord-est des etats-unis la nature
y est superbe
il ya des écureuils et bien que toutes
les maisons soit en bois les pins les
chaînes et les érables sont les amis des
hommes derrière le cadreur à quelques
pas le sait en atlantique et devant lui
né il ya soixante seize ans d'un père
français et d'une mère belge installé
ici depuis 30 ans marguerite yourcenar
marguerite yourcenar qui se veut la
servante des oiseaux marguerite
yourcenar
l'auteur de livres considérait déjà
comme des classiques de notre
littérature mémoires d'hadrien l'oeuvre
au noir souvenirs pieux archives d'une
heure et cetera
loin de paris elle s'est hissée au
premier rang des auteurs de langue
française à la seule force de son
poignet d'écrivain nous sommes à la mi
septembre et déjà l'humidité des
pelouses et des sous-bois gagne sur le
soleil
bientôt comme dans toute la nouvelle
angleterre il va faire très froid
et lorsque ces images passons sur vos
postes de télévision marguerite
yourcenar la réserve de bois fête sera
rentré à petite plaisance cerné par la
neige
entouré de livres greg chinois anglais
japonais elle va laisser courir sur le
papier sa culture son intelligence sa
sensibilité est ce qui fait qu'elle est
une grande artiste
la musique de seymour je veux savoir
marie dur sonar depuis quand sur votre
passeport à la rubrique profession ya
marqué écrivain bien nantis
réfléchissant je me rends compte que
c'est depuis 1929
c'était il y avait 25 ans et c'est la
première fois je crois roger précepteur
appellation officielle mais vous aviez
déjà publié un livre et j'avais déjà
publié un livre et je portais déjà
presque exclusivement le nom de mario et
personnels et abstenez vous pour vous
avez mais qui est devenu légal entre
temps mais ce qu'on décide de devenir
écrivain comme blue décide de devenir
pâtissière ou kinésithérapeute
je ne trouve pas immédiatement la
réponse parce que évidemment j'ai dû
probablement toujours pensé va
si je faisais quelque chose j'écrirai si
j'avais vécu dans une famille différente
c'est dans cette époque bègles musique
mais aucun talent pour la musique du
reste ou de peinture ou de quoi que ce
soit et il est possible que je me serais
tourner vers notre professeur je crois
pas il est quelque chose de sacré être
particulièrement écrivain je peux cette
question parce que dans votre premier
livre
alexis alexis un moment dit ceci il dit
il dit il manifeste sa volonté de
devenir un grand musicien aux musiciens
un grand écart bien sûr et il dit à
maman
enfant j'ai désiré la gloire est-ce que
vous enfants vous avez des enfants j'ai
désiré labeur en effet et la gloire de
l'écrivain je savais pas trop où je
voulais quelque chose d'important
qu'est ce que voulait dire par
l'important je ne sais pas avec quelque
chose qui intéresse les gens et leur
parler faire une impression c'est vrai
mais en plus j'avais même l'impression
que c'était d'arriver que ça se
passerait le sait pas trop pourquoi vous
en aviez secrètement le certainement
d'impression est ce que comme alexis vos
années d'enfance vous ont marqué à
jamais eu ni ceux ci des années
d'enfance ont déterminé ma vie non je
crois qu'on exagère peut-être cette
détermination par la référence dans le
canal et que c'est remarquer qu'à
l'écrit est un garçon très frêle
ambitieux c'est certain mais aussi
excessivement faibles et que par
conséquent il n'a peut-être qu'on s'est
peut être laissé déterminé par sound of
arrows
dans mon cas je me suis beaucoup moins
c'est votre mère étant morte quelques
jours après votre naissance est ce que
ça a été un manque grave dans votre vie
je crois que l'inter que le manga était
absolument nulle car en fait il est
impossible à moins de voir un caractère
extrêmement romanesque de s'éprendre de
s'émouvoir des personnes qu'on n'a
jamais vus par conséquent ongles la
personnalité de ma mère
pour ainsi dire n'a pas compté pour moi
j'ai commencé au moins d'occuper quand
je me suis dit que j'allais écrire
l'histoire de cette génération or la
miette ayant des transhumants romain
comme j'aurais choisi n'importe quel
autre sujet historique en quelque sorte
mais votre père qui la figure dominante
de l'art chiffres d'une heure à être
même exercé une influence considérable
sur la chine chez lui lorsqu'il était
toujours présent et pour cet été d'une
personne était extraordinairement
vivante un très grand vivant j'ai essayé
de décrire ça donne aux archives d'une
oeuvre et je continuerai dans quoi
l'éternité où nous voyons son âge ou
meilleur et alors curieusement ne peut
vous êtes les faits aux études à la
maison qui vous est devenu depuis un
certain temps saignante
oui mais ça ça a été à hazard de la
guerre même si trouver ici
arrivé pendant la drôle de guerre aux
états unis pour un séjour que je croyais
coup je croyais faire quelques
conférences est rentrés soit en grèce
soit en france entre temps la grèce a
été envahi la france était envahie quand
vous savez et il n'était plus question
de rentrer ni dans l'année dans d'autres
et aux parades avant vous aviez été
étudiante à rome notamment
j'avais fait j'avais suivi quelques
cours d'archéologie il part ça je ne
peux dire est que je parle que j'avais
été véritablement étudiants à dire
enregistrés dans une école à laquelle
j'appartenais si je fais allusion à
cette ce passage à rome ou d'étudiantes
c'est parce que il en est resté un linux
de la grève c'est sûr que là vous êtes
tenus le fascisme déconne lefa crise
j'en ai vu le jour de la marche sur rome
et tout ça mais évidemment beaucoup
marqué vous vous rappelez véritablement
vis vis au jour le jour la politique est
assez parce que le groupe dans lequel je
vivais très souvent des gens très
simples ou alors au contraire des
résistants déjà et le vivez eux et il
est bien certain que la première
rencontre comme je lui ai d'ailleurs dit
dans un lit
avec la brutalité politique sous quelque
forme que ce soit et peut-être plus
encore avec le mensonge politique
donc vous avez écrit donner du rêve qui
est un qui est un livre où il ya une
sorte de dénonciation du mensonge
politique comme on est le dire
et il sent qu après vous n'ayez plus
jamais aborder la politique j'entends
les affaires contemporaine l'usi aborder
enfin dans vos prix vers quelques ans et
non plus par les privés à propos de la
politique mais pas dans les livres
quoiqu'il y ait des normes et ya
énormément de référence à la politique à
la situation contemporaine dans la
plupart de ses livres il manière ou
d'une autre allusion ou sous le
déguisement de du 16e siècle ou par
allusion d'or sous bénéfice d'inventaire
par exemple l'éclat comparaison entre la
chute de rome et notre époque mais il
est vrai que je n'ai plus fait de
politiques actives
sauf quelques fois ici au niveau local
pendant les années de révolte contre la
guerre du vietnam où il m'est arrivé de
me promener avec un écriteau dans un bon
une fois c'est une cliente qui vaut la
peine d'être fait à bar harbor
mais vous avez participé à cette
manifestation spontanément ou est ce
qu'on vous a sollicité du ponte années
m'ont spontanément comme ça sert
vous avez vous saviez que cette
manifestation avait lieu une journée ici
je vais y aller bien sûr mais c'est tout
à fait inattendu c'est pourquoi mais
c'est contraire à tout ce que vous avez
dit depuis longtemps à savoir que
l'action au jour le jour où finalement
la ceinture du point de vue des clivages
aussi persuadé que l'accès au jour le
jour
à moins qu'on ne soit un journaliste a
pris aux journalistes par hugo avait par
exemple de ces noms là alors il suivait
l'action de jours il était capable de
l'exprimer au jour le jour
moi pas j'ai l'esprit d'escalier au
point de vue de l'action at il s'agit
d'un livre
mais quand il s'agit de la vie privée
évidemment qu'est ce qu'il vous plaît
oui mais là c'est quand même
extraordinaire jonas couvre feu je vous
imagine ferment votre porte ici et
disant bon ben je vais à la manif
là bas je ne dirais pas que le passé mon
temps à écrire aux sénateurs
et députés américains puisque même
marché américaine mar et je passe tout
de même un certain temps à le faire pour
protester contre ceux ci comme ça là
dessus et puis on envoie des télégrammes
au président vous en voyez vous des
programmes pour protester par exemple
d'un télégramme vous avez envoyé offre
toute espèce de chose maintenant pour
l'achat des territoires vierges au halal
dans la nascar pour défendre la nature
l'environnement d'alès quart contre les
dépenses le militaire excessive en
espagne vous pensez vos télégrammes sont
lus et sont certainement lui et ce qui
est bien plus ils sont pointés ce à dire
qu'un secrétaire passe son temps à les
compter parce que du point de vue
électoral savants et on vous donne des
réponses par est en soi assez souvent
des réponses à des réponses de qui de
jean de secrétaire le bac c'est
atterrant quelques sénateurs lui même
aux non les minorités ici joue un très
grand rôle et vous appartenez qu'une
minorité ou très grand nombre de
minorités je suis le boudin et la liste
des sociétés à laquelle j'appartiens ça
prendrait beaucoup de temps avant cette
émission alors vous êtes vous fait voir
vous faites partie de nombreuses
sociétés de traîneau moi j'aurais juré
au moins 40 au moins 48 dans deux ou
trois en france mais je le jure il
remonterait vous apparteniez aucune
souci antiraciste droit civil défense de
l'environnement défense de la faune
défense de la flore enfin si ça continue
défense de l'océan lapin j'appartiens au
groupe de costauds naturellement
alors on va ça c'est donc le xvème
siècle on va revenir un petit peu en
avant c'est à dire un siècle et demi
c'est à dire qu'au milieu du 14e siècle
avec umberto eco alors je dis tout de
suite donc si vous aimez les romans
policiers à la conan doyle agatha
christie
ce livre est pour vous puis si vous
aimez aussi les récits un peu subtile de
borgès se livrer pour vous aussi si vous
aimez les querelles les chorales
théologique se livrer pour vous aussi et
puis si vous aimez les rendements
historiques se livrer pour vous aussi
donc voyez c'est un vivier et ses fils
bibliothèque c'est un livre qui peut
satisfaire beaucoup de gens alberto
échos oui c'est donc 14e siècle s'est
tassée dans l'italie d'une heure c'est
une italie très différente de celle là
c'est une italie très différente parce
que mon histoire se passe dans une
abbaye bénédictine habité par deux mois
qui vient de toute l'europe
il ya seulement petit alien et qui vit
un corps dans un milieu qui n'est pas le
milieu de ville marchande qui sont déjà
un train de fleurir en italie donc c'est
encore un moyen âge un peu arriérés et
je le dis un certain point sur le
manuscrit que mon auteur assauts de melk
écrit dans le 14ème siècle mais
évidemment sa mentalité est la mentalité
du troisième du 12e et peut-être un
corner donc jura présentent plutôt un
dernier moyen-âge qui a déjà la
conscience qu'il ya quelque chose
d'étrange qui se passe under pour
commencer les gens commencent à parler
un vulgaire et à ce jour là le livre
commence cinq ans après six ans après la
mort d d'intel alighieri donc lorsqu'il
ya déjà une littérature guerre tandis
que le - demont abbaye continue à parler
entre en latin donc c'était il ya plus
d'un siècle
entre eux c'est l'histoire cette
histoire là et il y a il ya vraiment le
moyen-âge qui n'est pas encore arrivé à
la renaissance sauf à travers certains
livres et certains personnages parce
qu'enfin les livres qu'elle vaut
humaniste de couvre était là bas et elle
a de la découverte ce manuscrit est tout
à fait laventure de ces pionniers qui
sont allés piller les monastères pour
amener le livre alors le donc une abbaye
bénédictine
et puis deux personnages qui s'en
approche au début alors on peut dire
tout de suite que c'est sherlock holmes
et conan doyle simplement il s'appelle
pas comme ça ils s'appellent l'unss et
guillaume de baskerville et l'autre qui
est un ex inquisiteur et puis c'est il
ya son secrétaire qui est un novice
bénédictins qui s'appelle adso de melk
alors ils sont ils entrent dans l'abbaye
et là il s'est passé quelque chose
d'extraordinaire oui on peut des crimes
fois qu'il ya un mystère
il y as mystère il y a des - qui meurt
un par jour suivant parait-il a un plan
et suivant les déverser des citations de
l'apocalypse et oui puisque mon
personnage avait été un inquisiteur
c'est un inquisiteur en crise qui en
certains points abandonner ce métier
parce qu'il n'avait plus les idées
claires il ne comprenait plus d où était
la vertu les saintes et et où étaient
les crimes ce qui nous arrive souvent
est bon il est chargé de deux de
découvrir le mystère ma mettons qu'il
est chargé d'une autre entreprise il est
là comme ambassadeur de l'empereur pour
une rencontre très compliquée et il est
là en tant que lui un temps condisciples
où hamid et guillaume des eaux calmes
qui est un grand philosophe
l'époque et qui avait l'air d'être très
intéressé à la vie des mots et la vie
des signes pour pour dire l'histoire
d'une façon un peu cavalière et donc ce
personnage à trois peut-être plus que
trois problème la mission politique
ce petit jeu auquel il a décidé de
s'adonner dé découvrir les coupables et
sa curiosité sa cure et son amour pour
la conjoncture il faut dire qu'il
abhorre une année intelligence
exceptionnelle
et là il a une culture exceptionnelle
une intelligence exceptionnelle il faut
dire que les dialogues entre lui et son
et son secrétaire sont évidemment tout à
fait savoureux pas exceptionnel parce
que gilles lui fait dire c'est que des
gens à cette époque là on dit chez lui
mais dans sa bouche mais ça ne te feras
et qu'on lui confie la mission de
trouver la vérité parce qu'on sait quand
même qu'il a il a une intuition il a une
intelligence et une curiosité il a
d'ailleurs il est éblouissant veux pas
raconter ça mais quand tu n'entres déjà
il résout un problème humain
extraordinaire
oui mais ça c'est la faute à voltaire
league
alors si vous voulez m'obliger à dire
que guillaume est très sympathique mais
vous savez ce mon fils et je voudrais
bien sûr
bon alors il va se passer d alors là on
trouve tout les ingrédients du mystère
parce que il ya et il y a une et des
formules blizzard dont il faut découvrir
le sens il y à une bibliothèque eux dans
laquelle personne n'a le droit d'entrée
il ya des passages secrets il ya des
miroirs qui sont en vérité des portes
etc
et puis il ya des cadavres il y en a
qu'on retrouve noyé dans une baignoire
look on trouve la tête dans le seau ou
pour poser le sens du cochon qu'on n'ait
pu enfin bon des choses absolument
abominable mais lors des petites choses
que je trouve très très drôle moi par
exemple là vous êtes l'inventeur
je crois vraiment vous êtes l'inventeur
d'une forme de suicide qui n'a jamais
existé
le suicide par absorption d'un manuscrit
d'aristote ça c'est formidable ça je dis
rien le suicide par aristote c'est une
découverte génial
oui mais il ya déjà dans l'apocalypse
leader
livre à manger oui mais aristote ah oui
aristote ça ça c'est l'aspect nouveau
qu'est ce que vous allez faire plaisir à
beaucoup d'étudiants se suicider par
aristote c'est une chose qui est assez
joli alors on s'aperçoit finalement que
tout le drame tout le mystère vient donc
de cette salle afin de de cet empire
plutôt qui est la bibliothèque au centre
du monastère oui les problèmes si
bibliothèque fait pour conserver pour
distribuer ou pour cacher le livre c'est
un problème qui existe encore
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de
bibliothèques qui cache la bibliothèque
qui distribue et de bibliothèques qui
qui qui garde
mais à ce moment là est pour guillaume
c'est un problème culturel politique
métaphysique à la fois cette
bibliothèque qui est en même temps par
labyrinthe est une allégorie du monde
une allégorie de la recherche dans les
grilles de la vérité et est bon mais je
ne peux pas expliquer mais c'est très
mystérieux parce que si vous dites qu'on
a tué 2 - serrières il ya là le risque
c'est que avec son visiteur qui
deviennent un enquêteur et qui est comme
une sorte d'ancêtre de l'auguste du pain
qui va en vente et 1835 edgar allan poe
et qui il voit il sait que le premier
mort a été assassiné ceci n'est qu'il
n'était pas un accident c'est l'autre
qui meurent ensuite a commis un péché de
sodomie avec le premier mort et ça ne
m'intéresse pas alors que tous les
couvents tout l'abbaye pense que c'est
une histoire de moeurs qui se cache là
il sait innocent aucune importance ici
il y à une autre
je trouve que l'autre ait commis le
péché de sodomie c'est que celui ci qui
avait un petit peu c'est entrer dans la
bibliothèque lui a promis quelque chose
c'est quelque chose doit être
oui problème c'est la luxure de
l'intelligence hors qui ils découvrent
qu'ils au-dessous de la luxure sexuelle
signé et de la luxure des d'intelligence
et de savoir du savoir c'est le mot qui
est employé et du savoir et de d'une
conception affreuse de la vérité parce
qu'il y a des gens il ya là des gens qui
meurent et qui tue pour pour affirmer
pour imposer leur vérité qui est aux
mains un temps sa commune luxure
terrible aussi
alors justement prouve cette luxure du
savoir luxure de la chaire qui passe
aussi dans ce livre on vous la
connaissez vous la luxure du soir vous
la connaissez je disais tout à l'heure
vous étiez le roland barthes italien
vous la pratiquez cette culture et cette
luxure du savoir mais on écrit toujours
un roman sur soi même qu'il soit la
recherche ou san antonio on écrit
quelque chose sur ses propres vices oui
évidemment un intellectuel et vous avez
le risque de parler d'eux mêmes de la
dhuys décevoir du vice de la
connaissance vous avez le vis de la
culture vous parce que je lui ai tout de
suite si tes doigts une histoire
policière il ya aussi des pages
admirables mais alors sur les rebords
history sur notre seigneur jésus-christ
sur l'antéchrist sur l'architecturé etc
etc
ça c'est le vice médiévale alors le
moyen âge comme vie c'est comme passion
la la la la structure même des chapitres
qui chapitre par chapitre et puise
l'univers de la connaissance et est très
très médiéval et dans ce sens là je me
suis mis dans la situation d'un moine
j'ai essayé décrit comme il aurait écrit
les citations latines
alors les citations latines dont vous ne
donnez jamais la traduction non
traduites et je voyais tout de suite je
ne connais pas la table mais simplement
ont peu à peu près tous les sens et
toute façon on peut les sautés sanaa
important oui j'essaie d'expliquer à
quelqu'un qui m'a dit pourquoi tu n'as
pas traduit on se pose maintenant le
problème pour l'édition américaine parce
qu'on met bio mais les italiens le latin
le comprend le français
mais les américains c'est une grecque
pour pour le latin et aime ma réponse et
lorsque nous entendons une symphonie de
mahler nous nous comprenons très bien
qu'il fait des citations mais ce n'est
pas nécessaire de comprendre exactement
lesquels et c'est nécessaire dès de
comprendre qu'il ya un certain jeu un
signe de l'hésitation musique de la
citation et j'ai une autre réaction
intéressant dans jeune homme de 18 ans
auquel je demande
il me disait qu'il avait aimé le livre
est venu mais là on parle d'aidé
d'histoire ont pas de philosophie ont
pas il ya des citations latines et et
toi alors aller m'en fous il a dit parce
que ce sont deux façons de transformer
le labyrinthe des tridimensionnel dans
un labyrinthe tetra dimensionnelle
où il y à même la dimension
intellectuelle de la complexité et et on
découvre toujours à travers ses lecteurs
des aspects du livre qu'on ignorait un
vent j'ai beaucoup apprécié cette
réaction d'anne et vous êtes un jeune
homme digne hareng mais vous êtes très
pervers parce que en vérité cette
bibliothèque qui est le comble de la
logique nous amène à la confusion
cette cette abbaye qui paraît si haut si
elle aussi logique six agents s'aperçoit
que la nuit ça n'est que turpitudes et
mensonge etc
vous êtes terrible est alors en plus de
ça les jolies littéraire vous permettez
parce que le
de baskets basses car oui évidemment se
rappelle le shin beth services et conan
doyle
et puis le le l'octogénaire aveugle qui
avait été le vrai maître de la
bibliothèque
il a un nom qui ressemble à celui de
borgès etc vous vous amusez comme un fou
et je suis persuadé citation exacte des
citations fausses
à propos de ce lieu par vers vous
connaissez des autres lieux en dehors de
cette abbaye qui soit un peu moins
pervers
ici par exemple ces revers là on est
dans une zone de frontière
c'est sûr les délégations qui se sait
tout jamais nous sommes entourés par
billions de voyeur de nos spectacles
mais forcément c'est très important d'un
point de vue éthique ce sont le petit
traité qui vient à l'intérieur du point
de vue théologique par exemple je me
souviens d'un chapitre sur la métaphore
si la métaphore est quelque chose de
bien du point de vue spirituel où nos
essais qui est extraordinaire pourquoi
les rues de bourg l'aveuglent que les
patrons de la bibliothèque ne veux que
personne est taxée à ses livres
interdits dont il a fait empoisonner
tout le foeil à vous alors à la faut pas
dire ça aux malheureux faut pas dire ça
d'ailleurs c'était en 2006 n'ont point
ce n'est pas avec des barres à l'ail du
mat dans l'année de diane
on est assis une histoire de livres pour
les 1.2 et ça existe on le fait on l'a
fait jus du mal à trouver un poison qui
pouvait marcher et j'avais écrit même de
l'être un ami de l'université en lui
disant je voudrais un poison comme sa
compagne m'a répondu le poison que tu
cherches que c'est un certain point je
me suis aperçu que ces lettres dans mon
tiroir était très très compromettants et
je laissais détruite parce qu à après
avoir écrit le roman tout le monde
aurait pu s'apercevoir d'aider mon
innocence mais avant j'avais un moment
de deux revers vous êtes terrible alors
et j'espère juste cette citation parce
que c'est pour montrer votre humour
alors une conversation entre entre
guillaume et puis son secrétaire et là
ils cherchent évidemment les solutions
au mystère du du monastère mais alors
roseje commenté vous êtes encore loin de
la solution
j'en suis très près de guillaume mais je
ne sais pas de laquelle donc vous n'avez
pas qu'une seule réponse à vos questions
adso si tel était le cas j'enseignerai
la théologie à paris à paris n'ont
toujours la vraie réponse jamais dit me
dit guillaume
mais ils sont très sûrs de leurs erreurs
jean sinon il y à 7 ans quasiment jour
pour jour j'étais ici même dans votre
maison de lausanne en suisse j'étais en
face de vous pour un court entretien
télévisé et j'avais été frappé à ce
moment là par votre quiétude par votre
sérénité parce qu'on pourrait peut-être
appelé sorte de bonheur dans la
vieillesse
ils étaient inimaginables à ce moment-là
vous puissiez écrire et publier ce livre
terrible intitulé mémoires intimes
alors que s'est-il passé entre-temps et
mais il s'est passé beaucoup
d'événements y compris surtout un
événement capital pendant ma vie c'est
la mort de ma fille j'ai vécu toute ma
vie pour mes enfants c'est ce qui m'a
intéressé le plus c'est ce qui m'a
façonné le plus dans ma vie au point que
avant bien avant il ya des années quand
on me demandait un journalisme dans de
ma profession je répondais père de
famille donc je peux dire que j'ai suivi
les enfants depuis jour de la naissance
j'ai assisté à l'accouchement chaque
fois bien dès ce moment là je les ai
suivis en isère comprendre ce qu'ils
allaient devenir en essayant de
comprendre leur caractère je les fais
aussi bien pour mes garçons que pour
m'enrichir quand vous avez trois garçons
une fille et la fille c'est l'avant
dernière c'est la 21e' mais elle est
morte elle s'est suicidée et ses fils
et ça évidemment c'est un drame pour un
pêche a été un drame épouvantable
au début j'ai été complètement d'écraser
j'avais eu plusieurs moments vraiment
écrasé ma région à d'ailleurs voulu non
c'est par ce dernier je veux être
incinérés et que ce cendres soient
répandues dans le jardin
teresa et moi avons fait un matin tous
les deux elle a toujours avec nous mais
depuis lors
petit à petit c'est devenu cette douleur
s'est adoucie et je ne dirais pas que je
suis retourné à la sérénité
mais marie jo vit avec nous il tirait
bien nous en parlons
tous les deux comme c'est vraiment elle
était encore là et que j'ai retrouvé une
certaine sérénité
mais ce livre là voulaient mais crise et
pour la faire revivre c'est aussi pour
prouver votre amour qui est
effectivement immense pour elle et c'est
aussi me semble-t-il la volonté chez
vous 2 de dire aussi que vous l'avez
beaucoup aimé qu'elle vous a beaucoup
aimé et que s'il est morte ce n'est
quand même pas de votre faute
ce n'était pas de ma faute rien du tout
au contraire
d'ailleurs ces lettres et ses dernières
lettres ces derniers messages
ces derniers coups de téléphone et
cetera le pot nettement
j'ai toute une caisse de lettres adele
est de 2 km hors d'elle car elle garde
et où elle arrête ou classée et elle
m'appelle presque fait promettre qu'un
jour d'ingénieurs ce sera la même
couverture à la fin de vos mémoires
intimes effectivement 100 pages sont
consacrées à des textes de créer de
marie-jo des lettres qu'elle vous
adresser des poèmes qu'elle a écrit des
chansons qu'elle espère dont elle a
écrit les textes et des textes de
cassettes que vous en voyez c'est un
caractère étrange mari joue parce
qu'elle a peu tâté de toutes les
professions artistiques
oui elle avait elle été tentée par tout
ce qui est extérieur isation artistique
si je puis dire parce que l'art au fond
ce n'est jamais qu'une extériorisation
senna rejoint je parle de la vraiment le
créateur sénat mesure 1 je n'ai jamais
écrit dans une visée comment dirais-je
ni moral ni philosophique ni quoi que ce
soit esthétique mais vraiment pour nous
sortir le mans mène bien ma région
vespène besoins de son enfant dès son
enfance elle a pris des cours de dessin
des cours de peinture des cours de danse
de danses de toutes sortes de kelly
trouve ndt décrivait énormément disons
les choses carrément elle a été
traumatisée par des faits qu'elle est
traumatisée certaine
est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas pu lui éviter
ces félins hélas
et si j'ai désert ma région sa liberté
presque complète même complète comme
cela les amuse enfants d'ailleurs à mes
fils jamais je n'ai poussant des enfants
dans telle ou telle direction chez
eschoise d'aider à choisir eux mêmes
j'ai servi de garde-fou autant je n'ai
pu mais dans le calme la région
lorsqu'elle est partie j'ai continuer à
la soutenir autant que j'ai pu mais les
psychiatres même donc d'écouter louis
faure férié plus de mal on comment
dirais-je en exerçant un pouvoir
quelconque sorel et la vraie de sa
liberté entière
sané comme ça qu'elle peut comment
dirais-je se ressaisir il ya eu des
moments où elle avait une lucidité
parfaite
oui mais on la voit bien dans ses textes
et on la voit bien telle que vous la
décrivez elle est instable
elle est mal dans sa peau dorée elle
exige trop d'elle-même elle exige trop
de la vie comment vivre
qu'aurais je pu faire uniquement ces
faits qui ont été dramatiques dans sa
vie par exemple la découverte de la
sexualité avait quelque chose
d'effrayant en fourrière d'effroyables
mais je préfère ne pas rentrer revient
bien et on ne va pas en parler
d'ailleurs je n'en ai pas encore parlé
moi même mais j'ai donné simplement un
document de ma région elle-même sa tête
il racontera les ailes mais il ya aussi
le fait que l été elle comprenait pas
très bien vos relations avec teresa au
début elle était jalouse ont marre et
joue comme beaucoup de filles adorées
son père est bien marré jo voulez vous
voulez que je sois à elle seule oui mais
elle voulait tout mais c'est un amour
quasiment excessive quelques qu'elle
vous porte écouter les textes a sous les
yeux et vous appelle daddy ou dad
à 23 ans et vous écrit ceci je voulais
tant de choses lorsque j'étais petit de
pureté d'amour de soleil dans mes yeux
avec les grands bras forts d'un dadié
rien qu'à moi j'aurais voulu da dit
donnez l'univers tous qui frémissait
dans le fond de mon coeur la chaleur
d'un amour partagé avec toi et puis ceci
encore c'est vrai j'étais petit je
n'avais que sept ans mais je jouais ta
femme
et j'oubliais et maman et et d'autres
textes encore voici celui là que tout à
fait extraordinaire
et de sentir dans les yeux d'un autre de
son père un peu d'amour que par pudeur
on appelle affection et puis que par
pudeur on appelle même plus rien on
oublie on ne peut plus dire je t'aime
parce que c'est d'un autre temps c'est
fait pour des femmes c'est fait pour des
amants alors on dit je t'aime beaucoup
tu sais ce petit tu sais c'est pour
cacher le beaucoup et puis pour cacher
le j'ai osé dire je t'aime mm justement
taborea
l'incident de l'alliance un jour
lorsqu'elle avait 8 ou 9 ans en effet
est venu en ville avec moi je venais
souvent mêlé france et moi qu'elle
habille et à l'aller chez les marchands
de vêtements pour enfants etc
j'ai toujours habillé j'ai toujours
acheté tout ce qu'il lui fallait
et un jour elle me dit je voudrais bien
de petites bagues et nous sommes
entraînés un bijoutier est alors mieux
montrer les plus bas de l'enfant avec
une petite pierre bleue ou clair vous
savez et elle a dit non je veux la même
que daddy c'est à dire une alliance à
noter même pas encore connaître le nom
je suppose d'une alliance qui revenons
cette bague on a dû d'ailleurs dior
était sur une et jusqu'à sa mort à la
porte et aidants sont ces derniers vu
dans son dernier testament elle ne
recommande surtout de veiller à présent
l'incinération que sa bague sera encore
là et qu'elle soit répandue avec la
génération enfin avec ses sens une
lettre qu'il écrit un amant et il
termine c'est par cette phrase tu sais
je t'aime peut-être autant que mon père
et c'est plus que je ne pourrai jamais
en dire à quelqu'un et ceci aussi donc
c'est un petit peu la jalousie ne
comprend pas la place de teresa et alors
là c'est mc votre témoignage à vous
comme teresa nous a laissé seuls à son
habitude tu me regardes presque durement
et j'ai peur de comprendre c'est que
c'est vous qui vous êtes kim à nous qui
dit ça marie jo tu me dis en effet comme
étouffant de colère pourquoi elle et pas
moi tu ne comprends pas ma fille
comprendre quoi je te désigne le lit
teresa partage tout de ma vie et alors
elle vous répond ceci est alors est
alors voulez-vous que je fasse
qu'auriez vous fait à ma place j'étais
bien obligé de dire non tout le même je
ne pouvais pas en faire ma compagne de
24 heures par jour
à côté de la maison familiale ce génie
jean s'est fait construire spécialement
pour son travail une maison de deux
étages en briques et en bois ici une
grande salle bibliothèque où il a réuni
son énorme documentation au dessus le
bureau où il écrit et dans lequel sera
enregistré l'entretien
nathalie est plus que l'épousé avec sans
se gêner zine son unique collaboratrice
elle note classe tape répond conseil
chez les sujets ni jean pas de
secrétaire pas même une employée de
maison
non seulement nathalie s'occupe de
l'éducation de ses enfants
mais c'est encore el aidé de sa mère qui
fait le ménage et la cuisine
quant aux méthodes de travail de
l'écrivain elles sont méticuleuse et
rigoureuse excusez-moi alexandre ce
jezzine mais je suis stupéfait par
toutes ces fiches qui couvre toutes vos
tables à quoi sert-elle matériaux
irradiés technique vivent comme une tare
d'âge où je veux juste revenir hybrides
est encore au montage ou quatre ans des
collections mais pas ton community mais
qu'attend le milieu de journée et a mis
gravement en malinké coach qui y est dit
manning qui pose question 10 min à face
estime 10/14 auguste raux et rahman est
active ahmad un speech sur ce total il y
en a 12 ans big pavillon tim cook a pas
ton said i need is he has mais je me
jetais young au passage au nouveau
système
et quel est le quel est le rôle de
madame soljenitsyne tactile et #owni
ziani j'ai appelé ça je trouve cela va
aller crescendo et à l'aîné hier me
l'ait tap les textes de son père sur une
imprimante qui donne des pages analogue
à celle d'un livre et sur lesquels son
génie jean portera plus tard ces
corrections
[Musique]
stéphane le plus jeune lui aussi est de
son père si tu fais et stéphane matteau
n'empêche cela valait bien une petite
sieste
claude lévi-strauss mon premier
somme toute logique qu'est-ce que
l'ethnologie
à quoi servent les ethnologues et au
fond quel coin servi à quoi sert claude
lévi-strauss la dernière jeune je me
chargerai votre répondeur quoi faire
l'ethnologie au général vous savez c'est
une des nombreuses manières d'essayer de
comprendre l'homme
si on veut comprendre l'homme ont peu à
la manière du philosophe se replier sur
soi même et essayer d'approfondir les
données de la conscience on peut essayer
de regarder ce qui dans les
manifestations de la vie humaine est le
plus proche de nous considérer notre
histoire depuis ses origines
gréco-romaine jusqu'aux temps modernes
ou bien on peut essayer d'élargir la
connaissance de l'homme pour y inclure
même les sociétés les plus lointaines et
qui nous paraissent les plus humbles et
les plus misérables de manière à ce que
rien d'humain ne nous reste étranger
si je vous entends bien l'ethnologie ce
serait une sorte de continuation de la
réflexion humaniste sauf que vous allez
chercher les sujets les thèmes de cette
réflexion dans des peuples à comps
qualifier il n'y a encore pas si
longtemps de sauvages vous avez tout à
fait raison
car en fait ce que les hommes de la
renaissance ont entrepris c'est à dire
d'essayer de mieux se comprendre eux
mêmes à travers le regard sur l'homme de
civilisation qui a été des civilisations
exotiques je veux dire la grèce et rome
c'était une manière de mettre leur
propre société en perspective de se
mettre eux-mêmes en perspective et puis
après ce premier humanisme il y a eu un
élargissement avec le développement des
moyens de communication des grands
voyages d'exploration
on a intégré
le monde arabe l'inde la chine le japon
et l'ethnologie représente la troisième
est la dernière étape de cette
entreprise humaniste qui consiste à
essayer de comprendre l'homme par la
totalité de ses expériences et ses
réalisations
mais est ce qu'on peut dire des
ethnologues qu'ils vont chercher des
vérités des sagesses qui ne trouvent pas
dans leur propre société
chez eux je ne dirais pas ça parce qu'il
y a dans notre propre société aussi des
sagesses ne s'est pas du tout en train
de le rabaisser mais simplement nous
essayons de comprendre qu'il y en a
d'autres et que notre sagesse est une
sagesse parmi des centaines ou des
milliers car chacune des quatre ou cinq
mille sociétés je ne dirais pas qu'ils
ont existé depuis que l'homme est apparu
sur la terre parce qu'il y en a eu
beaucoup plus certainement mais sur
lesquels nous possédons quelques
informations ou qui existe encore bien
chacune représente une sage à sa manière
et le ne pouvant pas essayer de
comprendre la nôtre sans la mettre en
perspective par rapport à toutes celles
donc l'ethnologie nous invite à une
sorte de modestie d'humilité
je crois que ça a été en somme sa
fonction d'eux puisqu'elle est apparue
dans notre littérature si vous regardez
ses premières manifestations chez
rabelais ou chez montaigne car ce sont
les premiers qui est une curieuse et
ethnographique
c'est essentiellement dans leurs pensées
pour faire une critique de nos croyances
de nos coutumes nos institutions mais
par critique je ne voudrais pas du tout
employer un terme qui pourrait être
dépréciatif critiquer c'est essayer
d'analyser c'est essayer de comprendre
c'est d'essayer de mettre en rapport
avec d'autres modes de billets d'autres
modes de pensée je veux maintenant que
nous parlions claude lévi-strauss de
votre seul livre autobiographique qui
est célèbre et paru il ya bientôt 30 ans
était en 1900
quand 5 il s'intitule e tristes
tropiques je les relis j'avais lu à 20
ans j'ai relu à la faveur de cet
entretien
et je dois dire je le trouve vraiment
sublime et je trouve je le préfère j ai
trouvé encore plus de profits à cette
lecture et jeux des je conseille
d'ailleurs à tous ceux qui voudrait
aborder votre oeuvre de commencer par ce
livre ne serait pas ce qui se passait le
plus chatoyant parce qu'évidemment c'est
le plus facile à lire
alors est ce que vous vous rappelez que
triste à propos de tristes tropiques
il ya eu un communiqué l'académie
goncourt regrettant que ce ne fut pas un
roman sinon vous aurez donné le prix je
m'appelle là oui ça m'a beaucoup surpris
et est-ce que vous rappelez un
feuilleton de raymond aron très très
élogieux je me rappelle bien c'est ça
comptait beaucoup ça compte toujours
alors j'en profite pour vous demander au
passage qu'ils ont été vos rapports avec
aaron des j'admirais beaucoup l'oeuvre
de
aaron et j'avais pour l'homme une très
grande sympathie
en même temps nous nous sommes je dirais
assez peu connu nous nous rencontrions
au hasard de réunions professionnelles
mais je ne crois pas que nous ayons
jamais déjeuné ou dîné ensemble
alors quand on lit ce livre tristes
tropiques on se dit mais pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas choisi la littérature au
sens strict du terme pourquoi n'avoir
pas choisi le roman le théâtre voyez
côté ça je peux très bien vous expliquer
parce qu'à l'origine tristes tropiques
dans ma pensée c'était un roman
quand je suis rentré de ma dernière
expédition est du brésil
aude c'était au début de 1939 et j'avais
donc j'ai donc eu quelques mois pour
essayer de me re est incorporé à la vie
française avant la guerre et la
mobilisation et ses quelques mois je
voulais les utilisent et j'avais décidé
de les utiliser à écrire un roman est un
roman qui s'appelait tristes tropiques
c'était le titre et puis au bout de 50
pages
je me suis aperçu que j'étais en train
de faire du très très mauvais conrad
pour qui j'éprouve une admiration
éperdue et que j'étais pas fait pour ça
j'ai donc abandonné
et quand bien des années plus tard
1954 jean mallot vie m'a demandé
d'écrire un livre pour sa toute jeune
collection terre humaine n'est ce pas
qui en était à ses débuts
e j'ai écrit celui là qui n'est pas un
roman mais où en souvenir j'ai gardé le
titre de ce qu'ils auraient pu être ses
désirs tristes tropiques et uniquement
les trois ou quatre pages du roman qui
m'avait paraît pouvoir être sauvée ce
sont les pages imprimées en italie l'été
appelle un coucher de soleil
oui mais injuste sentait le début du
round mais seulement se coucher de
soleil qui resté célèbre
c'est vrai ces pages c'est pas je prouve
que vous savez admirablement écrit
raconté est dans les détails et j'ai pas
assez d'imagination je ne sais pas
inventer des jeux ne s'est pas créé des
personnages mais comment vous qu est ce
qu un ethnologue c'est bien quelqu'un
qui crée lui aussi des personnages ou
bien qu'ils sont vivants niveau il va
dans les détails des chercher je les
lirais qui les créent hélas parce qu'ils
les réinvente
mais enfin c'est parce qu'il voudrait
faire il voudrait être aussi exact et
authentique possible il voudrait copié
ses modèles
je me suis demandé d'ailleurs en lisant
soul hip si vous n'avez pas voulu
prouver d'une certaine manière que les
ethnologues ont eux aussi une âme une
sensibilité et même du style ça et c'est
un livre que j'ai écrit je dirais
presque dans l'exaspération est dans
l'horreur avant oui ça n'est pas du tout
ce que j'avais envie de faire j'avais
envie de faire de la science si vous
voulez et tristes tropiques a été écrit
en quatre mois enfin comme le oui je ne
crois plus que ces éditions sont datés
j'ai demandé que les dates soient
réintégrés dans la prochaine édition
livre de poche ça a été écrit exactement
quatre mois et comme une sorte de pain
somme dont il fallait absolument que je
me débarrasse parce que je n'avais pas
le goût de parler moi j'avais pas le
goût de raconter des petites histoires
des petits détails de voyage et en même
temps je suis bien obligé de constater
rétrospectivement qu'il y a
dans tristes tropiques une certaine
vérité scientifique et paix qui est
peut-être plus grande que dans nos
ouvrages objectif
pour autant que ce que j'ai fait c'est
de réintégrer l'observateur dans l'objet
de son observation
c'est un livre écrit avec ses objectifs
s'appelle l'oeil de poisson chat noir
qui vont être non seulement s'il ya
devant mais ce qu'il ya derrière
l'appareil de photo et donc ça n'est pas
une relation objective de mes
expériences ethnologique
c'est une relation de moi même en train
de vivre ces expériences ethnologique et
donc avec un tas de choses que je ne me
serais jamais permis d'écrire dans un
ouvrage à ambition scientifique
je le vends le sahb où ça bouge
à green ou ça vous fait plaisir que je
l'appelle star ça ne me chagrine pas
mais ça me surprend toujours j'ai
presque envie de me retourner un
revendeur de qui il s'agit mais j'ai
toujours voulu être célèbre comment dire
je vais pas m'en plaindre maintenant
non parce que vous êtes vraiment une
star aujourd'hui parce que la star c'est
quelqu'un qui a une grande notoriété une
grande popularité vous l'avez depuis la
bicyclette bleue qui a été un succès
phénoménal
vous êtes belle physique et vous êtes
riche maintenant et en plus de ça il y a
quand même et les plus grandes stars ont
toujours quand même une sorte un peu
d'ombré quand même autour d'elle et il y
à une auréole un peu de soufre quand
même qui vous qui vous suit et on va le
voir d'ailleurs avec avec ce roman le ya
une et karen cheryl la chanteuse a dit
de vous dans le france soir de lundi
elle dit vous étiez la marquise de sade
reconverti en comtesse de ségur
je trouvais ça c'est joli oui parce que
rien ne peut me faire plus de plaisir
que d'être comparée à la comtesse de
ségur que je considère comme un grand
écrivain du 19ème et qui a été ces
thèmes et même mes premières lectures et
je faisais j'adapte et même certains
moments de la campagne où je faisais des
pièces de théâtre avec et le marquis de
sade ne vous déplaît pas non plus a pas
du tout mais c'est d'autant moins que c
est un auteur qui va se retrouver
rééditer ces derniers temps et puis on
vous êtes une star parce que tous les
médias s'arrachent régine deforges
régine par-ci régine par là aujourd'hui
vous êtes soit la deuxième sur l'a5
demain vous serez sur l'a8 vraiment vous
êtes vraiment très demandée c'est bien
sous fait plaisir ça me fait plaisir
mais encore une fois je trouve ça un
petit peu étonnant et je me dis
quelquefois mais il ya donc pas d'autres
personnes pourquoi est ce qu'on me
demande tellement à moi en ce moment
oui non mais je sais aussi que les
choses sont d'une certaine façon pendant
un temps et que
demain après demain elles peuvent être
autrement donc si vous voulez je prends
plaisir à ce qui se passe maintenant en
dix ans demain est un autre jour
alors vous allez de faire paraître aux
éditions albin michel un court roman par
lettres intitulé pour l'amour de marie
sala et qui est née de la lecture de
carte postale tout à fait de découvertes
de cartes postales chez un brocanteur de
giroud et sur la cinquantaine de cartes
postales à l'acheter y en avait 3 dont
la lecture nous avait vraiment beaucoup
troublé via et moi et ce car ces cartes
c'était les lettres d'amour d'une femme
à une autre femme
alors le lendemain on sert précipiter
chez le brocanteur refouiller dans les
bois et j'ai retrouvé quatre autres
cartes postales et je me suis dit ça
ferait une belle histoire
puis voilà et puis on en trois ans j'ai
pensé tout en écrivant autre chose je
pensais à ce livre que j'écrirais un
jour et puis là n'ayant pas tellement le
temps de me lancer dans un dans un grand
roman qui demanderait un angle de
travail j'avais envie d'écrire
j'écris donc ça a été avant une autre
trilogie peut-être cette sorte de
récréation mais des gt2 tomber moi aussi
amoureuse c'est ça oui un tel que je les
imagine alors il ya les deux femmes
l'une s'appelle marguerite margot très
vite nous qu'elle va entrer dans
l'intimité de l'autre
alors elle c'est la conquérante c'est
l'amoureux c'est celle qui ne craint pas
le qu'en-dira-t-on qui est vraiment très
amoureuse de mari oui c'est elle qui va
en fait conquérir l'autre qui va faire
que cette jeune femme puisqu'elle sont
marié marié toutes les deux va oser
déclarer son amour à marie qui ne va pas
y être insensible les ça va être une
véritable salle et marie alors au
contraire elle est plus timide elle
craint ce qu'on pourrait dire dans le
village de leur amour et vous savez les
village de 300 habitants c'est toujours
un petit peu effrayant que ce soit en
1904 au maintenant donc elle a peur et l
on a une impression aussi que ce n'est
pas bien
éducation
chrétienne est encore très fortes elles
vont à la messe début du siècle
c'est au début du siècle donc il est
question marier toutes les deux toutes
les deux sont arrivés et qu'elles ont
même des enfants
oui c'est pas un contact et oui dans la
baisse ajoute quand même louis saha
s'ajoutent mais ça n'ajoute pas si vous
voulez ça n'entre pas dans dans leurs
amours le fait qu'elle soit mariée
toutes les deux ça les embête mais ça
n'est pas un élément de plus si vous
voulez oui pas facile parce que comme
lui ne va être enceinte
c'est une sorte de trahison de l'amour
c'est une sorte de trahison d'ailleurs
leur amour s'arrêtera là les est ce
qu'il n'ya pas la danseuse dans ce livre
je dirais presque une réminiscence
nostalgie de de vos amours de jeunes
filles pour des personnes de votre sexe
on pense aux cahiers volet sur écoute
est vraiment non on peut effectivement
on peut y penser je pense que des
lecteurs y penseront mais pas du tout je
me suis senti aussi à l'aise
on imagine en cet amour là qu'en
imaginant l'amour d'un homme et d'une
femme
tout d'un coup j'étais l'une ou l'autre
oui sauf que c'est un hameau qui est
très contrarié parce que il doit se
cacher sans arrêt sont des lettres
la preuve c'est qu'elle se disent
l'essentiel par lettre elles se disent
l'essentiel par let et puis j'ai essayé
de ne pas tous trop dire parce que je
crois beaucoup aux non dits dans l'est
dans les romans je crois beaucoup que le
lecteur doit avoir sa part de travail
dans la lecture ou dans dans pour le
développement de l'histoire pour ce qui
m'intéressait de se décider de ne pas
trop dire ce qui se passait autour d'un
oui d'ailleurs le l'endroit où se
passent aux amours finalement et eu
enfin mon succès une grange mais c'est
tout mon groupe
aucune des deux ne va faire la
description à l'autre de la grange bien
sûr que non plus qu'elle la voit tous
les jours qu'elle se voit tous les jours
mais vous en revanche vous voyez très
bien la grange et j'allais dire comme
s'il y était comme si vous y étiez
mais vous évidemment voulait cette
description vous la gardez pour vous je
la garde pour moi parce que je pense que
le lecteur il peut aussi bien voir cette
grange que moi et vous êtes plutôt vous
personnellement porté vers le vert
margot la conquérante ou plutôt vers
marie celle qui se laisse conquérir a
plutôt margot plutôt marrante
je suçais festayres alors j'ai quand
même qu'il y à toujours quand même une
auréole de soufre autour de vous sur
votre tête est ce qu'il n'ya pas de
votre part quelques perversité à mêler
le nom de françois mauriac à ce roman
dont peut-être qu'il n'aurait pas tout à
fait approuvé le contenu moral parce que
vous dites que il les pages ont été
écrites à malagar dans sa dans sa maison
si vous voulez je dois énormément à
cette maison je les dis dans une courte
préface
sans ce lieu il n'y aurait pas eu le
lieu où est située la bicyclette bleue
et je me c'est un endroit d'un cage que
j'ai aimé dans lequel je me suis sentie
senti bien c'est en fait la maison que
j'ai pas vu quand j'étais petit j'avais
vraiment l'impression de me retrouver
dans un lieu dans un lieu et met
d'ailleurs le livre est dédié à malaga
mais il n'est pas il n'est pas dédié à
françois mauriac une citation de
françois mauriac
oui une citation de france en manque
mais qui et qui est lié à malaga volet
s'éteint
c'est un lieu que j'ai aimé et que
j'aurais aimé sans la présence
[Musique]